mientras el confinamiento en europa se
alarga las protestas se extendieron de
nuevo por las calles el sábado hubo
manifestaciones contra las restricciones
por el cob y 19 en georgia rumania
alemania y suiza en bucarest la capital
rumana los manifestantes salieron a la
calle por séptimo día consecutivo para
mostrar su rechazo a las nuevas
regulaciones que incluyen un 'toque de
queda' a las 8 de la tarde
no
no estamos protestando contra el virus o
contra una evidencia médica porque
estamos contra las restricciones a
nuestras libertades las restricciones y
las medidas no deberían seguir siendo
obligatorias
entretanto miles de personas marcharon a
la ciudad alemana de stuttgart para
mostrar su descontento con el manejo
gubernamental de la pandemia sólo unos
pocos participantes llevaban tapabocas o
mantenían la distancia de seguridad como
requieren las autoridades según dijo
usted dice michael foster obstante
ustedes penalizamos y hacemos
seguimiento de las violaciones de las
reglas contra el coronavirus pero no
tomamos acciones severas contra
manifestantes reunidos de forma pacífica
de leyes de un dice fundando un show la
actuación en la ciudad suiza de sant
golem sin embargo las protestas y
desembocaron en violencia grupos de
jóvenes atacaron a la policía con
artefactos caseros
y esto respondieron con gas lacrimógeno
y balas de goma 19 personas fueron
detenidas pero ya han sido liberadas las
protestas a lo largo de europa tienen
lugar en medio de un aumento de los
contagios por coronavirus mientras las
vacunaciones siguen estancadas en las
primeras fases